- So your birthday is tomorrow.
- Yes.
(crowd cheering)
- [Man] Happy Birthday.
- Thank you. Yeah. December, baby.
- I know, I love that.
So are you looking forward to like
almost being in your thirties?
- Yeah. I'm inching closer.
I'll be 29. It's like,
yeah, I need all the advice.
- [Host] My thirties were
cooler than my twenties.
- Really? I hear that a lot.
- Yeah. I'm very sure my
forties will be cooler
than my thirties.
- Yeah, it keeps getting better.
(laughs)
- No, it does keep getting better.
I will tell you, I feel like,
do you feel like that as
you age, you get like,
I don't know, like wiser
or more like (indistinct)
- I mean, that's the
goal I feel like, right.
It's like, hopefully we
get better as we get older,
but yeah. But no, I'm excited though.
I think there's something
about like stepping
into my thirties. It's like,
it doesn't feel super scary.
I'm like, okay,
I'm kind of becoming more of
like who I am and stop caring
about what people think, I
guess, like stepping into that.
So we'll see.
I think music will be more fun
to just like trying new things. So.
- Oh my gosh. And with your
voice, like you can sing
anything. So...
- You too.
- Yeah. Whatever.
(crowd laughing)
You're like a run queen.
I'm like, oh my God.
- I fan girl you every time I'm here.
- [Host] Ditto. Literally.
I remember I was running
into this a long time ago.
I was just like, God, your
voice is an incredible,
you can literally sing anything.
I got to ask you though.
What's like your favorite decade so far.
- It's always the decade I'm in.
I always think it's the best.
Yes. It's always the best.
We're all so fortunate.
- [Host] I think you're
living the right way
when you say that.
(crowd cheering)
When you answer it like that.
- Yes Honestly.
- Do you ever run into
those people that are like,
oh my God, I miss high
school. And I'm like, what?
- [Man] Yeah. Right.
- I was like, I could not wait
to get out of high school.
I was like, you go to these
people and they're like, oh,
I just loved it. And I'm like, no, no.
- No.
- I loved it.
- [Host] Oh my god. It's
not that I hated it.
She said, I wouldn't be
like, let's repeat that.
- Yeah. No, I don't need
to go back. But I loved it.
- It's like, let's leave it there.
- [Man] Right.
- [Host] Way back there.